The conflict reaches Israel's leadership
as a minister's son is reportedly
wounded amid ongoing attacks.
Hezbollah fire injures the son of
hardline Israeli Minister Bezalel
Smotrich during clashes at the border.
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's what
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters Masjid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another Masjid
around the area of Norway subhanallah
where there's so many Muslims that do
not have somewhere to pray. This Masjid
is only $500,000 and any donation that
you give will go towards your akhirah
because when you enter that grave
nobody's going to remember you except
Allah subhanallah wa ta'ala. So make it
count brothers and sisters and donate
towards this Masjid inshallah. A new
project that's only $500,000 and believe
me if every single one of us give 1
pound, 10 pounds, 100 pounds, 1,000
pounds, that's going to be something you
will never regret on yawm al-qiyamah and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go but your deeds on yawm
al-qiyamah are not.
Donate to the link inshallah. Let's get
to the video. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullah wa barakatuh brothers and
sisters and dear friends. Hope you guys
are well. I've got some amazing news for
you guys. Yes. I I I just love sharing
these news for you guys. Uh usually I am
somebody like everyone knows. I think
any decent human being would never like
to see any innocent person getting hurt
because not only are we Muslims but the
way Allah subhanallah wa ta'ala Allah
subhanallah wa ta'ala by his mercy that
he's given us subhanallah that we don't
like to see innocent people get hurt.
But that changes when it is an idea of
soldier. When it is a genocidal idea of
soldier who is pro-genocidal who who out
outwardly just openly records themself
in 4K committing a genocide
and laughing about it when the Gaza and
children are starving. These people
these vile people
are saying yeah we want we want children
we've killed children we've killed
babies. Yes it's
we've they're proud about you you can
never in history see someone who openly
brags and says yes we do this. Well I've
got something amazing for you guys. It's
going to taste better than the dessert
the the the the red velvet cake my wife
makes. This I'm my wife I'm I'm just
going to tell you this this beats your
red velvet cake. Yes I'm so sorry. I'm
so sorry I have to say it. I'm talking
on the
on that matter my wife calls me. Let me
see what she has to say.
Yeah assalamualaikum I'm just filming
the video and I'm just talking about a
red velvet cake.
Yeah and I said that there's something
that tastes much better than a red
velvet cake.
What's that? Well an idea of soldier the
Smotrich. So basically the defense
ministers son got nearly well he's in in
he's in a coma. So I said this tastes
this news tastes better than your red
velvet cake. That's what I was just
expressing to the camera.
Yeah okay I have to go now cuz yeah I'm
recording right now I need to go. And
this going to be part of the video. Okay
assalamualaikum bye-bye. Bye. Okay yeah
she's she she she she said I I that I
agree she said that I agree. Okay so
let's get to the trending inshallah. So
let's watch the videos of uh Smotrich uh
the one who's uh said that you know um
new king starving them all that kind of
stuff. Well let's see the videos for
ourselves and let's enjoy get you guys
get your uh popcorns out inshallah
please.
Far-right Israeli Finance Minister
Bezalel Smotrich says shrapnel tore
through his son's liver during an attack
near the Lebanese border. Alhamdulillah
that it tore through his liver. May
Allah subhanallah wa ta'ala make him
tear his flesh apart
uh more. Yes uh subhanallah I hope he
has a painful painful death.
Uh yes I hope Allah subhanallah wa
ta'ala rips his soul apart when his soul
is coming out. Uh yes you bloody
terrorist. That's what you guys are. You
maniac genocidal maniac. Okay
uh subhanallah may it rip his flesh out.
I mean that wounded eight Israeli
soldiers. Uh sorry I mean to all the
eight Israeli soldiers as well. Sorry I
just singled out just your son there for
forgive me. I totally forgot and all the
eight Israeli soldiers and all of the
IDF together. In a post on X Smotrich
said a mortar round was launched towards
the soldiers on the Lebanese border on
Friday. One of them is my beloved son
Benyahu Hebron he wrote.
The far-right Israeli cabinet member
said shrapnel penetrated his back and
stomach and he was rushed to hospital.
By the grace of God one of the shrapnel
tore through his liver and lodged in the
wall of the largest blood vessel in his
stomach. If God forbid it had been
damaged the situation would have been
much worse.
By by the mercy of God.
My friend maybe that's the only mercy
that we say is maybe a chance for your
son to change for the better. If not may
Allah make sure he's sending him back
inshallah. Please cuz they they can't
fight the children you know when they
fight men whoever it is then you know
it's a they can't fight the children
kids and babies and stuff like that you
know but when they fight actual men they
go fight men to men men to men combat
you know it's their janazah. You can see
IDF soldiers 10,000 of them wounded
disabled. May Allah increase them. I
mean According to Smotrich his son's
condition is improving. Benyahu thank
God is strong and determined and with
God's help after rehabilitation and
dedicated care he will recover and
return to full strength and the IDF.
I mean let him send him back to the
front lines please. I mean please. Oh
please send them back. I can't wait to
hear the news of his destruction.
However he noted that additional
soldiers were also wounded in the
incident. Unfortunately several more of
his comrades were seriously injured and
we are all praying for their recovery
together with all the brave IDF wounded.
Yeah okay so there we go. I'm going to
look at some pictures as well. There are
some images as you can see from his
uh his son in a coma
subhanallah which you can see. Here's
another video. Let's just see for
ourselves inshallah. The conflict
reaches Israel's leadership as a
minister's son is reportedly wounded
amid ongoing attacks.
Hezbollah fire injures the son of
hardline Israeli Minister Bezalel
Smotrich during clashes at the border.
Doctors say shrapnel seriously injured
Smotrich's son near the Israel-Lebanon
front lines.
As Iran's war of revenge intensifies
even Israel's political elite now feel
the impact firsthand. With casualties
mounting Donald Trump predicts the
conflict will end soon a claim Iran
quickly dismisses. Hezbollah rocket fire
near the Lebanon border injured eight
Israeli soldiers among them the son of a
senior minister as fighting along the
northern front intensified. Finance
Minister Bezalel Smotrich said his son
sustained serious injuries when shrapnel
pierced his liver but narrowly missed a
main artery preventing a fatal outcome.
The strike occurred amid a broader
offensive by Iran's regional allies who
launched coordinated attacks under what
they called revenge for Khomeini.
On March 9th Smotrich confirmed publicly
that his son had been wounded while
serving near the Lebanon border
expressing both concern and defiance in
his statement. So guys there you go and
you can see in this picture besides me
on the left and the right subhanallah
here's hugging his son and his son comes
back in as you can see coma either they
come
in a coma
as a vegetable or they come back in a
body bag and we're okay with any of
those. We are okay with them coming back
with a disability
with mental psychological issues
coming back in a body bag coming back in
a coma coming back you you you name it.
We are okay with all of those out
outcomes. So yes I thought I'd just
bring that good news to you brothers and
sisters. Like I said to you before may
Allah subhanallah wa ta'ala deal with
these oppressors these genocidal maniacs
and deal with them and Allah subhanallah
wa ta'ala the blood of the Gaza people
are not going to just go in vain. God is
going to deal with them. The divine
punishment is going to come. I thought
I'd bring that to your attention guys.
Hope you enjoyed it. Share this with
your family and friends. Please please
watch it slowly. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullah wa barakatuh. Everything
you own from your clothes to your car to
your wife or your husband is going to
forget you and move on and be replaced
the moment you die. That's what Allah
says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters Masjid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another Masjid
around the area of Norway subhanallah
where there's so many Muslims that do
not have somewhere to pray. This Masjid
is only $500,000 and any donation that
you give will go towards your akhirah
because when you enter that grave
nobody's going to remember you except
Allah subhanallah wa ta'ala. So make it
count brothers and sisters and donate
towards this Masjid inshallah. A new
project that's only $500,000 and believe
me if every single one of us give 1
pound, 10 pounds, 100 pounds, 1,000
pounds, that's going to be something you
will never regret on yawm al-qiyamah and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go but your deeds on yawm
al-qiyamah are not.
Donate to the link inshallah. Let's get
to the video.